>>> A 1960s PLAQUE EMBLAZONED
WITH T WORDS KU KLUX KLAN, NO,
IT'S NOT A HIDDEN HISTORICAL
RELIC OF A RACIST ORGANIZATION.
ACTUALLY, THAT PLAQUE IS STILL
HANGING OUTSIDE THE SCIENCE
BUILDING AT WEST POINT.
NOW, THE CONGRESSIONAL NAMING
COMMISSION WANTS THE PENTAGON TO
INCLUDE KKK MEMORABILIA IN ITS
EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY AND RENAME
CONFEDERATE MARKERS IN MILITARY
INSTITUTIONS.
CNN'S NADIA ROMERO REPORTS ON
THE OBSTACLES BLOCKING CHANGE AT
THIS SITE AND OTHERS.
>> A NEW SCHOOL YEAR BRINGS NEW
HOPE IN THE YEARS-LONG FIGHT TO
CHANGE A TRIO OF NAMES THAT LOOM
OVER THIS BUILDING AND TWO
OTHERS IN MONTGOMERY, ALABAMA.
ROBERT E. LEE, JEFFERSON DAVIS,
AND SYDNEY LANIER HIGH SCHOOLS.
MELVIN BROWN GREW UP IN ROBERT
E. LEE'S HOMETOWN.
TODAY HE'S THE SUPERINTENDSANT
OF SCHOOLS, JUST WEEKS INTO HIS
TENURE, HE'S INTENT ON SEEING
THE NAMES GO.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE WHO
BELIEVE WE'RE TRYING TO ERASE
HISTORY.
>> THE GENTLEMAN FOR WHOM THIS
BUILDING IS CONSTRUCTED AND
NAMES WAS A BRILLIANT MILITARY
TACTICIAN.
AT THE SAME TIME, HE WAS A
SLAVER.
AT THE SAME TIME, HE LED A
REBELLION AGAINST HIS OWN
COUNTRY.
>> THE MONTGOMERY BASED EQUAL
JUSTICE INITIATIVE, CHALLENGING
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC INJUSTICE,
HAS LEE HIGH WAS NAMED IN 1954,
AS RETALIATION OF BROWN V. BOARD
OF EDUCATION.
JEFFERSON DAVIS HIGH NAMED 1968,
RIGHT AFTER INTEGRATION.
AS OF 2021, EJI IDENTIFYING MORE
THAN 240 SCHOOLS IN 19 STATES
NAMED IN HONOR OF CONFEDERATE
LEADERS.
IN RESPONSE TO GEORGE FLOYD'S
MURDER, SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE SOUTH AND BEYOND PLEDGED TO
RENAME SCHOOLS NAMED AFTER
CONFEDERATE LEADERS.
IN ATLANTA, FOREST HILLS
ACADEMY, NAMED AFTER ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF THE KU KLUX KLAN, IS
NOW HANK AARON NEW BEGINNINGS
ACADEMY.
IN BATON ROUGE, LEE MAGNET
SCHOOL RENAMED LIBERT ARMAGNET
SCHOOL.
IN MONTGOMERY, ALABAMA, WHERE
THREE HIGH SCHOOLS HAVE AN AT
LEAST 80% BLACK POPULATION,
CONFEDERATE SCHOOLS STILL
REMAIN.
BUT SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER LISA
KEITH ARGUED CHANGING THE NAMES
WOULD BE MORE DIVISIVE THAN
HELPFUL.
>> MY PERCEPTION OF THIS WHOLE
THING IS THAT IT'S DIVIDED US AS
A BOARD.
AND IT IS DIVIDED US AS A CITY.
>> DESPITE THE OBJECTION, THE
SCHOOL BOARD HAD ENOUGH VOTES TO
CHANGE THE NAMES OF ALL THREE
SCHOOLS IN JULY 2020, BUT MORE
THAN TWO YEARS LATER, NOT MUCH
HAS HAPPENED.
>> A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
>> ONE OF THE MAJOR OBSTACLES
SLOWING THEM DOWN IS THE ALABAMA
MEMORIAL PRESERVATION ACT SIGNED
IN 2017 BY KAY IVEY.
WILL SAYS IF THEY CHANGE THE
SCHOOL NAMES WITHOUT GETTING
STATE APPROVAL, THEY COULD FACE
STEEP FINES.
>> THERE ARE FINES THAT HAVE
BEEN COLLECTED TO PAY THOSE
FINES.
>> AND MORE MONEY WOULD BE
NEEDED TO CHANGE EVERYTHING FROM
SIGNAGE TO LETTERHEADS TO
UNIFORMS.
A PRICE TAG THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
HASN'T DETERMINED.
BUT AS SUPERINTENDENT BROWN SEES
IT --
>> THERE'S NO PRICE THAT IS TOO
STEEP TO HELP KIDS AND THEIR
WELLBEING.
>> HERE IN JACKSON, MISSISSIPPI,
THE SCHOOL USED TO BE ROBERT E.
LEE ELEMENTARY.
NOW IT'S SHIRLEY ELEMENTARY,
NAMED AFTER TWO PROMINENT BLACK
DOCTORS WHO HELPED DEVELOP
MEDICAL INSTITUTIONS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE.
THERE'S A SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
VIRGINIA WHO CHANGED THE NAMES
OF SOME CONFEDERATE NA